IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
( APPLAUSE )
TODAY WAS PAUL MCCARTNEY'S
BIRTHDAY.
THE LEGENDARY BEATLE TURNED 72
TODAY.
SO WE HAVE TO HONOR HIM BY
RUINING SOME OF HIS BEST WORK.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#BADBEATLESSONGS.
>> OH!
>> WHAT!
EXAMPLES WOULD BE: YELP!, OR
LUCY IN THE SKY WITH UNMANNED
DRONES, OR
NORWEGIAN MORNING WOOD (THIS
BIRD HAS GROWN).
SO HERE'S MY ASYMMETRICAL DONG
THONG.
>> OCTOPUSES OLIVE GARDEN.
>> YES, POINTS. MIKE.
>> I WANT TO HOLD YOUR HAM.
YEAH, SURE, POINTS. DAVID.
>> YESTERDAY-- NO MAYBE-- NO, IT
WAS YESTERDAY.
>> OKAY, GOOD. POINTS.
>> MICHAELA.
>> I GOT TO GET YOU INTO MY
TRUNK.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> WELL WHILE MY CLEANING WOMAN
GENTLY WEEPS.
>> MICHAELA.
>> GOOD DAY, SUNSHINE-- I SAID,
GOOD DAY!
>> POINTS. SHOWALTER.
>> LUCY IN THE SKY WITH ALMONDZ.
>> DAVID WAIN?
>> SHOUT AND TWIST.
>> YES!
YES, POINTS, I'LL GIVE I THAT,